so I'm a big believer in having a
schedule and having a routine and having
a calendar that supports you and your
goals and planning things out but I'm
also big believer in following the flow
and in being creative and not being
stuck in the same thing over and over
again and I think that that can lead to
boredom and that can lead to you losing
motivation for your goals and so how I
balance that is most days I will follow
my schedule right i have my routine
that's what I'll follow but then when
the days when I wake up with a creative
idea something want to test something
that I'm getting in the zone in the flow
up I go with it because I think that one
I'm probably gonna come up with
something amazing and two if not at
least I won't live with regret wondering
if I what would happen if I tried it so
that's how i balance it out and today is
one of those days today's my book
writing day and I decided that today I'm
going to try to write from starbucks I
usually write from my living room on the
floor with my laptop on the couch it's
kind of relaxing and today I thought you
know what it's a beautiful day outside I
just got my new vibram shoes let me
pause here so you can see them and i
thought i'm going to walk the starbucks
i'm going to make this video while i do
it test out my new shoes is the gorgeous
day here in Toronto aunt city and at the
same time I'm going to read so there's a
whole bunch of research that I have to
do for different projects especially for
writing this book and I don't have a set
time in my schedule for reading so with
that I'm going to use this time that I
have it's probably taking about 45
minutes to walk to the starbucks and I'm
going to run back and I think it's going
to take about 20 minutes we'll see i'll
see how it goes when i'm at the
starbucks going to do the work of my
book and change it up see what happens
and so I'd encourage you guys to do the
same thing you know first off have a
schedule that supports you have a
routine that supports you schedule
things in that logically makes sense it
if you do these things that'll help you
with your goals but then don't always
stick to that that's not you know gospel
when days come when you're creative and
want to try something follow that flow
because that's likely going to create
some magic for you now this this series
is about my book and me right
look and usually after go my rent like
this I answer your questions and there
were no questions last week there were
no question because all you guys wanted
to talk about was my beard all you
wanted to talk about was my beard so I
shaved it off no more beard back to
business and if you have a question you
want me to answer about my book or about
the book writing process that you're
going through and you want to advice or
help leave in the comments below and
next week I'll make a video response so
thank you guys have a fantastic week
continue to believe I look forward your
comments and I'll see you soon